come on would you tell actors of a
certain ethnicity who come to Hollywood
who made me feel that they're typecast
in rules would you say hey I know
there's a glass ceiling as we call it
but at least you're working or there's a
way to break through so that maybe you
are given leading man roles a form for
me and I'm not trying to break through
at all for me I'm doing my job and I
have a wonderful career in my country
and and it was very simple to work with
great people like Ridley Scott anymore
Ivan and fill him down linemen of course
was Savin the citizens and I've met with
many people from everywhere and didn't
take a genius to together together at
all and I do what I believe and if I'll
ever own I would take it if I don't love
it I will not take it and I will not
encourage anyone to not to be himself
just be yourself
for me this is don't try to please
everyone at a time everybody no no
please ourself
as much as you're not harming anyone as
much as you're doing what you believe as
much or as you're helpful as much as
you're raising positive defeating
negatives yourself and that's it
and concerning the question that some
people needs to to change their name in
order to get to work or you know what in
our profession actors everywhere you
will find producers and directors they
will tell you this the right name that
you want to give to people that they
will love and or it's going to be famous
or we have to choose your name to be
sexy to be attractive to be whatever and
they will some Americans originally they
changed the name actors I mean William
method our great actor in the movie he
changed his name it happens my name was
five names was too long Khalid Mohammed
will never we solid with our it's it's
it's a very very and and you can find
some of it coming from Muslim names and
some of it even coming from Christian
names and you know what I mean do with
artists is you don't find usually in
Muslim families but we choose Novoa with
with some of the professionals in the
profession your name can be changed and
your you're a good guy no problem
you